[Music]
civilization it's pretty easy to take it
for granted huh we all live in it and
rely on it every day
in fact our modern lives are so embedded
in this social construct that it can be
quite difficult to imagine life without
modern society
but what if all this were to come to an
end
imagine for a minute that our days on
planet Earth were numbered say some sort
of ecological disaster happened the
meant the earth could no longer support
the human race what we do stay put and
face extinction or perhaps take a lesson
from civilization beyond Earth I look to
the sky for a new home but how realistic
is this answer could he really abandon
earth and start afresh on another world
[Music]
now I first played civilization when I
was just a wee boy with my dad and big
brother and you know what that game
taught me so much I learned all the
names of all the capital cities I
learned that you need magnetism for
navigation in order to get the really
big boats but most important of all I
learned that despite what history tells
us dandies are right in bastard
but could this latest entrance in the
series also teach us about space
colonization well I caught up with Lewis
Darnell UK Space Agency research fellow
and novelist and I asked them if our
days as a society on earth were really
numbered could we also escape to the
stars with current technologies day it's
not possible so to pack seven billion
people into spaceships and then travel
not just within our own solar system but
in the enormous distances between the
stars but with kind of current
technology take tens if not hundreds of
thousands of years to travel to the
nearest stars and in our galactic
neighborhood but let's say that in the
future we do develop suitable technology
maybe we discover new kinds of physics
that allow sci-fi things like wormholes
or warp drives then perhaps maybe not
taking all seven billion or the entire
population the planet then but a small
cadre of colonists and then send a seed
of the earth to another world and
establish a colony in another solar
system
[Music]
okay so let's say that we are part of
this lucky group members of this
pioneering expedition once we actually
make planet fall before we could really
start to build a civilization we need to
make sure that we don't just you know
die straightaway your priorities at
first are going to secure your own
safety
perhaps a check there's no indigenous
life forms and I don't mean just kind of
dinosaur like reptilians that might come
and crash through your habitat and start
gobbling you but bacterial life as well
if you want to do some kind of
biological survey to make sure there's
nothing there that threaten you if you
start exposing yourself to that
environment is the prospect of alien
diseases you see because our human
immune systems are so attuned to life on
Earth and attacked from the microbes
live here who would have very limited
protection if any against microorganisms
living on this new world but what about
after that point say we do the survey
and everything seems to be fine how do
we actually go about turning this alien
world into home once you've settled down
the next steps are going to be to reboot
an extraterrestrial civilization for
yourself so you can have to ensure
transport networks you're going to want
to be up short in your colonists but
even more fundamentally you're gonna
want to start prospecting for the
natural resources on this new planet
you're going to want to identify where
the seams of metal awesome so you can
mine them and smelt them but he's metal
to build more habitats and expand
because the colony spaceship you arrived
in is only be able to provide a certain
amount of resources before you've
disassembled all of it and you're gonna
have to start living off the land on the
new planet you've arrived on ok so
that's all pretty exciting but remember
completely unfeasible with current
technology so let's get back to reality
if we were to colonize somewhere else
maybe in our solar system perhaps are
there any possible candidates the place
in our solar system the humanity in our
future is most likely to colonize
sattell is going to be our next or
neighborhood is going to be Mars if you
do call my smells and build up this
Martian population it'd be by sending
small numbers of people who make babies
with each other and there would be
genuine Martians born in the next
generation but the long-term problems
you have to solve for colonizing Mars
might be something like terraforming how
would you move beyond living inside a
kind of space habitat where you have
pressurized capsule and grow your own
food inside internal greenhouses how do
you make the next step to actually
living outside on Mars making the
Martian environment a lot more to
restaurant lot more Clement and the kind
of technologies that people talk about
the kind of challenges will have to be
solved involved pumping up the
atmosphere on Mars so it's a high enough
pressure that water can once again flow
on the surface and maybe seeding the
Martian soil with lichen of sign of
bacteria can start growing in very
hostile conditions and releasing oxygen
to start building up air that one day
humans might be able to breathe without
a spacesuit
so this prospect of humans colonizing
Mars certainly seems possible but when
is this likely to be something you and I
get to witness or maybe even take part
in hopefully the first mission will be
within my lifetime within our lifetimes
but because Mars are so far away and
such a long mission to be at least two
years to go to Mars and come back again
with the the orbital dynamics it's gonna
have to be very big complex and
expensive mission and therefore most
certainly a multinational effort will be
something like the International Space
Station effort but launching a ship to
another planet so including Europeans
and Americans and then perhaps the
Chinese and Russians all working
together to build this interplanetary
ship to set it sailing to take people
the first time to another world and you
know what this could maybe even be
sooner than that a project called Mars
one made headlines a few years ago when
the non-for-profit organization based in
the Netherlands announced that a plan to
send the first colonists to settle Mars
in as early as 2023 pretty much the
whole process from the final stages of
selection to ultimate planet fall and
beyond
would be televised - it does sound kind
of crazy like big brother in space
except they would never get to leave
that's right
Mars one is a one-way trip exactly how
realistic this is and whether or not it
will actually happen well only time will
tell
so would you like to be one of these
volunteers on a one-way trip to Mars or
would you only be game if actually took
you beyond our solar system let me know
in the comments down below or by
reaching out to me on Twitter at camp
Fras Rob oh and more for how to rebuild
civilizations why not check out Lucy's
book called the knowledge how to rebuild
our world from scratch it's really great
and available from all good book shops
and some lousy ones too last week on
reality check I discussed the science of
crisis style invisibility now in the
comments on youtube user flea play TV
said this guy in vsauce are like a smack
of intelligence to your brain thanks
that's a huge compliment now if you
don't know Vsauce you should totally go
and check out his stuff granted it's not
all about games but his episode on is
your read the same as my read is
hands-down one of my favorite things on
YouTube thanks for watching guys and
remember we've got a ton more great
original programming right here on
GameSpot you should totally go and check
out Danny's latest episode of the point
when he looks at misleading game
trailers as for reality check well I'll
be back here next week so see you then
[Music]
you
[Music]